I've got five numbers here and the goal
is to order them from least from least
to greatest and it might be obvious to
you that all five of these numbers are
negative numbers so let's just think
about which of these is the greatest
number and you might be tempted to say
oh well you know 40s would if these were
all positive 40 would be the greatest so
you might be tempted to say negative 40
is the greatest but you have to realize
what the negative is telling you and to
think about that think about if these
were your dollar amounts in your bank
account would you rather have negative
40 dollars in your bank account or
negative seven dollars in your bank
account negative 40 means that you owe
the bank 40 dollars
so it's 4 T less than having nothing
negative 7 would mean that you own the
bank only 7 dollars so it's actually the
case that negative 40 is less than
negative 7 and out of all of all of
these numbers it is the least of all of
them so negative 40 is the very least
that you could view that's the least
amount of money that you would want out
of these comparisons in your bank
account or the smallest amount of money
you owe the bank $40 not only do you
have nothing you owe the bank $40 then
the next smallest number would be
negative 30 it would be negative 30 and
then the next smallest after that would
be negative 25 negative 25 and then the
next smallest after that would be
negative 10 negative 10 and then finally
the greatest of all of these numbers the
greatest and I will do it in pink the
greatest of all of these numbers is
negative 7 and if it's still not obvious
to you could also think of them in
temperature and temperature terms which
of these is the coldest temperature
whether you're talking about Celsius or
Fahrenheit negative 40 would be the
coldest temperature negative 7 would be
the warmest temperature there would be
the most heat in the air at negative 7
another way to think about it is we
could draw a number line so let's draw a
number line right over here if this is a
0 and you know we could put maybe
positive 7 up here positive 7 isn't one
of these numbers but then we can plot
all the other numbers so this right here
might be negative 7 if that's negative 7
then
maybe this right over here would be
negative 10 notice we go further and
further to the left of zero and then we
go a little bit further to the left we
get negative 25 a little bit further to
the left than that is negative 30
negative 30 and then you go even further
to the left you go even further the left
and you get to negative 40 so look at if
you think of it this way the least of
these numbers is the one that's furthest
to the left of the on the number line
and the greatest of the what is the one
that's furthest to the right